Tania's in Illinois hey Tonya how are
you hi thanks for taking my call Dave
I'm so pleased this week with you you
too what's up well I'm hoping you can
guide me I think I've made a big mistake
my husband and I just started doing your
plan in August and it's been amazing but
we're on baby step 2 but this has to do
with an old 403 B that I've had
nothing's being contributed to it but
earlier in the year back in April we
went to the financial planning services
that my company sponsors and pays for
and they did a full workup and I had
been kind of having sleepless nights
because my my value would go from I'd
lose like $20,000 you know and then I
get anyway there was a lot of risk so
they suggested that I moved some money a
hundred and sixty six thousand into a
traditional annuity within my 403 B
retirement account guaranteed so right
now 30% of my 577 that's thousand that's
in there is now in this annuity and now
that I've started listening to you we're
following your steps I'm starting to
realize that probably what's a huge
mistake yeah and I don't know what to do
I'll contact them and see if they can
reverse that and put it back into mutual
funds okay cuz um they said it would be
like a 10-year process that's taking you
know attempt out each year and so that's
so they put you in something inside of a
retirement account with a surrender
charge oh I don't know
no these guys are absolute screwballs so
I need to if yeah it's in my my 403 B
and it's some kind of retirement
Saamy penalties are what your surrender
charges are and and you may be stuck
there but the other thing you gotta
weigh it against is you're probably
making 2% on this thing instead of 10 or
12
okay and so if you're if you're if your
surrender charge is 10%
take it and move it put it in something
that makes 10% more the first
you recoup okay gotcha
what makes once you know I don't know
what your surrender charge is though the
stupid thing might be 40% I don't know
so call them and ask them about syringe
Oh tell them tell them that you are
really upset now that you learn what it
is they actually sold you that you they
put you in a surrender charge product
inside of a retirement account which is
absolutely screwed up that's ridiculous
I mean you've got two sets of penalties
on this money now if you get if you need
to get to it right the government and
these idiots
yeah so now I don't know I don't know
what they're gonna do but see if what
they can do to get you out I would tell
them you're not happy with them and we
want to get you moved and see if you can
lean on them a little bit and get it
moved and then get some advice from
somebody else before you make any more
moves and like a smart vest or probe
that has a clue what they're doing so
Wow all right let's stop a second what
is an annuity an annuity is a life
insurance company product it's a savings
account with a life insurance company
there are two types of savings accounts
with life insurance companies fixed and
variable fixed pays you basically a CD
rate one or two percent right now which
is what she's in and it grows inside of
an annuity tax deferred like a 401k or
an IRA does and you pay extra fees for
the annuity so here's what's happened
you have a tax deferred 403 B and they
moved her into a substandard horrible
rate of return that she's paying extra
fees for and is also tax deferred that's
redundant there's tax deferral on the
tax deferral you can't double dip on
this you get one shot at this
and she already had all that for free
because it's inside the 403 B it didn't
need to be in an annuity
but she got scared with her risk
tolerance with the stuff moving back and
forth and so these groups dropped her
into this thing why is that bad because
then they put you on a surrender charge
and then it takes seven years to be able
to get your money moved out of there
without getting hit with some kind of a
charge and gut-punched and so there is
zero times never not a case anywhere
that a fixed annuity is the answer
never there's always something better
because a fruit jar at least doesn't
penalize you when you take the money out
early and you're not making much more
money on it than the fruit jar anyway
you can also do a variable annuity which
is a fine product but not inside of a
retirement account the variable
annuities are mutual funds inside of an
annuity and they have some actual
benefits after you've maxed out all of
your retirement accounts not against
variable annuities once you've maxed out
everything and you paid off your house
but you'll need to use a variable
annuity inside of there you're paying
extra fees for the tax deferral and the
benefits of the annuity and you don't
need to pay for that because it's
already in the side of a retirement
account
[Music]